Good morning, Hank, it's Tuesday, I'm in the office
So I don't know if you've seen Sarah's brilliant art assignment video, The Case for Kanye West,
but after watching it, I've been listening more carefully to
Kanye's music, and there's a lyric in the song "Power" that's really
stuck with me. It goes, "They say I was the abomination of Obama's nation. Well, that's
a pretty bad way to start a conversation." I think the grammatical ambiguity of "that's a pretty bad way to start a conversation"
is important here. Sidenote! Don't tell me Kanye didn't mean any of this because he's not that smart or whatever
One, authorial intent doesn't matter, and two: Kanye is that smart. I mean,
sometimes he's an offensive buffoon, but so are a lot of smart people.
Right, so, saying "You're the abomination of Obama's nation" is indeed
a pretty bad way to start a conversation, right? Because you're calling someone a name, you're also
using cleverness to make yourself seem correct.
But "They say I was the abomination of Obama's nation" is also
a pretty bad way to start a conversation, I mean, first off, you're using a non-specific "they"
as a way of constructing a false us-versus-them dichotomy
Also, most Kanye haters weren't actually calling him "the abomination of Obama's nation"
they were criticizing other things about him and his work, but then Kanye simplified
and repackaged those arguments in a way that made them seem ridiculous.
You see these bad ways of starting conversations a lot in contemporary discourse.
Think of all the "got you" moments in the political 24-hour news cycle
and the use of diminutives and name-calling.
I mean, from Canadian Cruz to Crooked Hillary, to Lying Donald to Barry Obama, they all
they all undermine and demean people in a way that's, like,
a little too vague to defend yourself against.
There's the rhetorical questions, the certainty of one's own opinion,
wit masquerading as accuracy, the sharing of one study
you read about once instead of doing the research to learn
what the bulk of evidence currently points to....
The presumption that those who disagree with you are merely wrong--
the list goes on and on. My favorite at the moment is where you accuse
a voice you don't like of being shrill or shouty
or aggressive, even when it isn't, which is a tactic
so meta, even Kanye couldn't parse it.
I do this too, by the way. Like the other day I said on twitter
that forty percent of U.S. gun sales
involve no background checks, which turns out to be
a totally unsupported statistic
but by the time I did the relevant research
the tweet was already out there, furthering the ceaseless
spread of misinformation.
So I don't get a pass on this one.
But research shows that rude, aggressive,
and inaccurate comments don't just lower
the overall quality of conversation, they also
make people feel more angry and afraid.
And while I think Kanye is right about
all these bad ways of starting conversations,
they're effective ways to start conversations
because we all feel compelled to respond.
Like, hostility generally gets answered with hostility.
And when the outrage button gets pressed inside of us
we want to share and reply
and do all the other things that the
architecture of social media currently values.
So trolling is poisonous, but it works.
And that's why the front page of most YouTube comment sections
doesn't contain the most interesting, or generous, or nuanced comments,
but instead the most controversial ones.
And I know those controversial comments get replies
but I don't think they change anyone's mind.
Like, screaming at each other is a bad way of listening,
but I think it's also a bad way of getting heard.
Now I realize that's easy for me to say since I already have a platform
but I truly don't think anyone has ever changed their mind
because they were called an idiot.
Hank, I really loved your video last week about race and racism
in the United States, but the comments section
was a disaster.
Until, you made a 'hankschannel' video asking people
to simply reply with a plus sign to comments they agreed with.
That immediately tricked the YouTube comment algorithm
into valuing generous and thoughtful comments
which, in turn, made commenting far more civil and productive.
It's a small thing and it wasn't perfect but it made
a real change in that online conversation,
and I know I'll be using the plus sign reply from here on out.
Nerdfighters, if you have other suggestions for how we
might improve the quality of conversations both here
and in the wider world, I'll be in the comments
doing my best to listen.
Hank, I'll see you on Friday.